there is a sequel
to tiger king that is going to be
released next week you decided to sue
netflix to try and keep you know you
wanted to keep yourself out of them and
including you at all did they ask you to
be a part of it or did you just
proactively say no like i want to make
sure that i'm i'm kept away from this
they have been going around to people
who were in tiger king asking them to
sign new release forms so as soon as
they contacted me they said hey we just
want to clear the air and i said lose my
number and that was the end of it
lady
peaceful what happened to don lewis
carol knows something
he was dealing with some shady
characters down in costa rica
don't like to play with dentures
i'll kill you for that
so i don't know what they were gonna say
or do but i was shocked to see that they
were using my images in their trailer
and that was why we filed the suit
because they didn't have my permission
to do that will you watch it i'll have
to because no matter what is ends up
being in it you know that they're going
to trash talk me again and so i have to
be prepared to do what i did last time
and say no here's all of the evidence
that proves these lies are lies and so
i'll have to be able to do that when you
were first asked to be a part of that
show what kind of show did you think it
was
we were being told that it would be the
equivalent of black fish for big cats
and so we wanted that sort of thing
exposed with the big cats that they
shouldn't be in cages so when did you
find out that's not exactly what
uh the show that they were doing at the
end of episode seven
because we had no idea that it would
even be called tiger king we called him
up when we saw the trailer and we were
like what's that about who's doing that
show
and all of a sudden they didn't want to
talk about it well i mean one of the
things that's happening of course kate
mckinnon is playing you in a peacock
series i know you said you would have
liked meryl streep to play you if
someone's going to play you but now that
you've seen kind of kate's
transformations because we've seen some
pictures what do you think well she's
still a lot younger looking and a lot
prettier than i am
i
she's an amazing talent so i'm sure that
she will
play it well i have no idea what their
script looks like i don't know if it's a
comedy when you think about the people
that are in it she hasn't reached out at
all to like talk to you would you if she
wanted to kind of talk to you pick your
brain anything would you sit and talk to
her sure
i am never going to financially recover
from this a judge in court awarded you
joe's
cat property so when you went in there
what did your team discover a lot of the
things that we had suspected for years
like i had seen joe exotic on some of
his little internet videos
talking at a fundraiser where he would
say if you pay a thousand dollars to
dance with me i'll give you this tiger
tooth well that's illegal to sell tiger
parts and what we find in the carol
baskin's cage fight
with the help of his family members is
saying yeah he cut the teeth out of all
of those cats and was making jewelry out
of them which was illegal but i believed
it was true but now we can prove that it
was true now there's news that his
sentence could be reduced
how are you going to feel or how are you
prepared if he ultimately does get out
the re-sentencing has not happened yet
but i trust that the judge will give him
the ultimate sentence that he can under
the new guidelines we have taken all
kinds of precautions to protect me and
my family and the sanctuary and so we
may have to step those up even further
but right now we've done about all that
we can to ensure our safety people want
to believe something that's just totally
outlandish and so it it has been a
problem how did it most impact your life
the thing that hurt me the most about
the fact that my phone was ringing every
two minutes for the next three months
was that i'm on call whenever a bobcat
gets hit by a car or there's orphans
i'll go anytime anywhere in the state of
florida so i have to head out two
o'clock three o'clock in the morning to
the scene of a bobcat that's been
injured i had to turn my phones off
because my phone was ringing 24 7. i
couldn't sleep at all and so all of
those bobcats that died as a result of
me not being able to use my phone
because people got a false impression
from tiger king was what hurt me the
most you now want to tell your own story
we were told tiger king is a documentary
about the abuse of wild animals it
turned out to be a reality tv show at
best
i've been going after animal exploiters
for decades
joe exotic is one of them and he's in
jail how much is this documentary
setting the record straight to who carol
baskin is it's not so much trying to
rebut tiger king as being a show about
what we are all about what we've been
doing for 30 years so it's just the
cameras coming along with us
doing the investigations that we do
finding who these bad guys are and then
bringing them to justice that's why they
hate us that's why they say the things
against me that they do so you and
howard with the help of others you guys
um investigate the business of the
people who own and allegedly profit from
big cats right so why are why are you so
passionate about ending private
ownership of big cats we will lose the
tiger in the wild in the next five years
wow if we don't stop the captive
breeding of big cats and the reason is
all of those cubs that end up being used
until they're 12 weeks old and then they
can take a finger off of a child they
end up being dumped into private hands
killed for their parts so we have to
stop the cub petting and the private
ownership to save the tiger in the wild
i have to think this is dangerous for
you yeah i mean because you deal with
the idea of you're going after these
people who that's their livelihood right
you're going after them to shut them
down the public only knows about the
murder for hire plot that happened in
tiger king but these people have been
threatening to kill me for years they
don't want me to talk about why these
cats don't belong in private hands and
they will do anything to stop me when
people watch this what do you ultimately
hope they come away with when they're
done when people see carol baskin's cage
fight i hope the thing that they are
most impressed with is the fact that we
have to all work together to end the
abuse of these big cats so that we can
save them in the wild before it's too
late
i know a lot of people talk about
breeding them in captivity for the idea
of releasing them back to the wild if we
lose them how stupid is that we need to
save them in the wild where they
currently are there is no release
program for big cats to go back to the
wild and couldn't be because it takes
years for them to learn how to be the
apex predators that they are
[Music]
you